- [Narrator] We'd like to thank
NordPass for supporting PBS.
The American dream,
it's the idea that in the United States,
upward mobility is available to everyone.
We're told from an early age
that if you work hard and sacrifice,
one day you too, will
have a beautiful family,
money in the bank and of
course your very own house
with a white picket fence.
- Today, we don't really appreciate
how radical this idea is.
For most of human history,
real estate was where
money and power were wholly concentrated
and only the most connected
and wealthy families
could be landowners.
- Since the 19th century,
millions of people in our country
really did climb the
socioeconomic ladder this way.
The creation of a burgeoning middle-class
was a remarkable achievement
and a revolutionary step
towards a society in
which wealth is shared
more evenly amongst its citizens.
But the ugly truth is that for decades,
the federal government
intentionally created programs
that ensured the dream
only became a reality
for one type of person.
And to this day, we are
dealing with its consequences.
(gentle music)
- Back in the 1930s,
our country was reeling
from years of economic depression
and housing was in crisis.
Many banks had failed,
causing them to call their loans early,
contributing to a wave of foreclosures.
Home ownership across the
nation hovered around 45%.
And the housing inventory
that did remain, was tight.
Especially for those in the
middle and lower classes.
- In response, Congress passed
the National Housing Act in 1934,
which created the Federal
Housing Administration.
The FHA's job was to make buying a house
affordable to the everyday person,
mainly by offering to
insure certain home loans
against borrower default.
This government sponsored safety net
gave private banks and
lenders the confidence
to extend much more generous terms
than had ever been available in the past.
Like 30 year mortgages,
higher lending limits
and low fixed rates.
The sort of things we
take for granted today
and it was a resounding success.
The FHA helped take the
country's home ownership rate
from 43.6% to just under 70% by 2005.
Heck, we even got an FHA loan
when we bought our house back in 2010.
Thanks FHA.
- But there's a very big difference
between the original FHA mortgages
and the ones we have access to today.
Nowadays, approval for an FHA mortgage
is based on your personal
financial situation
and credit worthiness.
But originally, FHA mortgages
focused on some other factors.
Let's crack open the 1936
FHA Underwriting Manual.
Shall we?
It stated, if a neighborhood
is to retain stability,
it is necessary that
properties be occupied
but the same social and racial classes.
Schools should not be
attended in large numbers
by inharmonious racial groups.
If the children living in such an area
are compelled to attend schools
where the majority of the peoples
represent a far lower level of society
or an incompatible racial element,
the neighborhood will prove
far less stable and desirable.
- So, to quote the FHA,
communities of color
were branded as undesirable populations
and their mere presence would
have a detrimental influence
on the housing prices surrounding them.
But this stance was not
supported by any evidence.
In reality, when people of
color managed to buy homes
in mostly white neighborhoods,
the property values would go up
because they were willing to pay more
due to the shrinking housing
inventory available to them.
- Nevertheless, cities across the nation
ended up being divided into
specific zones by the FHA
and local housing authorities.
The areas where whites
were more concentrated
got the green light for
those sweet FHA backed loans.
But the areas with higher concentrations
of communities of color and
immigrants were sectioned off
on maps with red lines
to indicate they were not
eligible for FHA loans
regardless of individual
financial credentials.
This practice, now
referred to as red lining,
also occurred for new
affordable developments
popping up in suburbs.
Many of those builders even
added language to deeds,
known as restrictive covenants,
with phrasing like no
property shall be sold,
conveyed, rented or leased to any person
not of the white or Caucasian race.
Yep, it was that explicit.
- The combination of federal policy
and private sector reinforcement
was devastatingly effective.
Between 1934 and 1968,
black families specifically,
received only 2% of all
federally insured, home loans.
And housing segregation tightened its grip
on the American landscape.
It wasn't until 1968 that title eight
of the Fair Housing Act finally outlawed
housing discrimination.
Think about that.
For 34 years, an entire
generation of people
denied access to one of the
biggest tools of wealth building
of the entire 20th century.
It's depressingly easy to find evidence
of its impact all these years later.
- According to the federal reserve,
the typical white family today,
has eight times the wealth
of a typical black family.
And five times the wealth of
the typical Hispanic family.
This is in large part, due to
home equity being bequeathed
from one generation to the next.
Nearly 30% of white families
report receiving an
inheritance or monetary gift
from family compared to
10% of black families
and 7% of Hispanic families.
- And even though it's been 52 years
since those FHA policies
were ruled unconstitutional,
the gap between white home ownership
and black home ownership is
the worst it's ever been.
And even if a black
family does own a home,
the typical value of it is only 65%
of the average white families.
We even see this sort of divide play out
in the most elite circles.
Of the 616 billionaires
that call America home,
only seven are black and none of them
the product of inheritance.
- And honestly, the deeper
you go on this subject,
the more it feels like
you're peeling back layers
upon layers of rotted,
termite infested wood.
Housing policy directly impacts education
because we fund our public
schools via property taxes.
Lower property values means
less money for schools
resulting in lower graduation rates,
lower college attendance, et cetera.
Then there's the impact on
policing, incarceration rates,
mental health, even our diet.
Areas with higher concentrations of black,
Latino and indigenous Americans
are far more likely to lack easy access
to fresh and affordable food,
creating what are known as food deserts.
This leaves the residents of these areas
more susceptible to chronic health issues.
- We here at Two Cents, deeply believe
that taking ownership of your finances
can completely change the game.
But we collectively have to acknowledge
that the cards are not fairly dealt.
We are perfect examples of this.
We take our financial
responsibilities very seriously
through budgeting, saving,
and living within our means,
but we are fourth generation homeowners.
And when we bought our FHA
insured house a decade ago,
we were graciously gifted
some of our down-payment.
Our net worth, like everyone else's,
is due to a combination of
choice and circumstance.
- We also hope this show helps strip away
the taboo from money talk.
How can we find solutions to issues
that we aren't educated on
and don't converse openly about?
This subject is no different.
As the writer, At-Nehisi Coates puts it,
All of our solutions to the great problems
of healthcare, education,
housing and economic inequality
are troubled by what must go unspoken.
- Hopefully, if enough of us honestly talk
about this rigged game,
we just might be able to see
more people actually win.
And that's our Two Cents.
- And that's our Two Cents.
- We'd like to thank
NordPass for supporting PBS.
NordPass is a new
generation password manager
where security meets simplicity.
NordPass remembers your passwords for you
by auto-filling your
username and password.
You can organize your
logins and private notes
in a secure password vault
with access to them all
with one single master password.
There is auto fill with a click,
so you don't have to scroll
through hundreds of passwords.
With one click, NordPass will
automatically fill them in.
There is zero knowledge.
Your data is encrypted on your device
before it reaches their
servers for backup and sync.
For more information about the deal,
go to NordPass.com/twocents
and use the code twocents.
- Hey everybody, we are back to answer
some of your questions and
reply to some of your comments
on our last episode, which was
should the U.S. government
balance its budget?
- All right, our first comment
that we're gonna address
is from John L., he says,
"all my life I heard
that the U.S. government
could print money if needed,
I just thought it was an
old wives tale, until now.
Am I understanding this correctly?
If they find themselves in hot water
that they can just print some more money?"
Also, is the U.S. the only
country that can do this
or others can as well but we
never hear about this ability?
- What John is alluding to here,
is what economists now call
modern monetary theory.
It's just a theory, but
it's kind of this idea
of maybe we should start thinking about
the government printing
more money differently.
So to this first part of it,
can they just kind of make more money
to get out of hot water?
No, not necessarily
because making more money,
especially to a higher degree,
does devalue the money.
And so you can't just do this infinitely
or every time you get into trouble.
- And I actually don't know the answer
to that ending question, which is,
is the U.S. the only
country that can do this?
I'm assuming not, right?
What do you know about this?
- So not every country can do this.
You have to have a sovereign
currency for this to work.
So because the U.S. has its own currency,
the dollar, we can do this
because we fully control our own currency.
But the Euro zone that has
a lot of different countries
with the same currency, the Euro,
cannot do this in the same way
because they can't just print
more euros in one country.
It's sort of a different system.
- So, our second question
comes from Robert Murray.
Do you two have any strong opinions
about modern money theory?
Like what Stephanie Kelton and
L. Randall Wray talk about?
Again, this is a theory,
so it can only be proven through practice,
but we have a pretty good history
that seems to prove this to be the case.
- I just listened to an
amazing podcast on this
from Planet Money.
It was just called modern monetary theory.
They interview Stephanie Kelton,
who is kind of one of the
forefront thought leaders
around monetary theory
and hearing them talk
through these ideas and a lot
of the old ways of thinking
that we kind of talked
about in this episode,
which is got to balance our budget,
we can't go into infinite amounts of debt.
That has kind of proven not to be true.
- And finally, we
definitely want to address
the somewhat elephant in the
room that Nope brought up.
He said, can you guys do a video
on this whole GameStop thing?
We actually shoot videos
pretty far in advance,
so it's not really in our capability
to have something happen
and then pump out something
that week for it.
But what we've decided,
after talking about it,
that what we want to do
is take the opportunity
to dig more into the idea of derivatives.
- I think it's so interesting,
the kind of match that
ignited the whole 2008 crash
was derivatives.
If you've watched the
Big Short or anything
kind of exploring that a little bit.
And this whole GameStop thing,
all about derivatives too.
- So thanks so much for
letting us know how you feel
for chiming in and for watching us.
We really appreciate it.
And we'll see you next time.
- See you later.
- Thanks to our patrons
for keeping Two Cents financially healthy.
Click the link in the description
to become a Two Cents patron.
If you want to get into the nitty gritty
of the home buying process,
check out our video on the
path to home ownership.
(cheerful music)